في المقابل قال علي القحوم القيادي في
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين عضو المكتب
السياسي للجماعه في تغريده له على منصه
اكس ان قواتهم ترد بقوه على البوارج
الامريكيه البريطانيه في البحر الاحمر من
جته قال القيادي في جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين حسين العزي ان اليمن تعرض لهجوم
عدواني واسع من سفن وغواصات وطائرات حربيه
امريكيه وبريطانيه وقال انه سيتعين على
امريكا وبريطانيا الاستعداد لدفع الثمن
الباهظ وتحمل كافه العواقب الوخيمه لهذا
العدوان
السافر من صنعاء مراسل الجزيره محمد
العطاب نعم هذه العمليات
والتي ظلت صنعاء والمدن اليمنيه بعيده عن
الاستهداف لفتره طويله اكثر لاكثر من اشهر
بعد توقف التحالف بقياده السعوديه هنا
نشهد البارحه عمليات جديده شنتها ثنائي
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا حسب الاعلان
هما و وجاء استهدافهم ما ما استهدف امس
حسب ما تحدث به قائد قوات الجويه
الامريكيه انه استهدف ما يقارب 16 موقعا
لكن ما وصلنا او ما استطعنا ان نحصيه هو
ما يقارب ثمانيه الى تسعه مواقع نذكر منهم
منها
قاعده الديلمي في شمال العاصمه صنعاء
وايضا محيط مطار الحديده ومناطق في مديريه
زبيد ومعسكر في كهلان شرقي صعده ومعسكر
اخر ايضا يدعى اللواء 22 بمديريه التعزيه
وكذلك معسكر في الجند واخر في عبس في ساحل
تهامه هذا الهجوم حسب مصادر محليه غير
رسميه ايضا دفع قوات صنعاء الى شن هجوم هو
ماك ده
المتحدث نائب نائب رئيس التوجيه التابع
لجماعه انصار الله بانه شن هجوم على
البوارج الامريكيه لكن لا نستطيع ان نؤكد
ايضا دون دون تاكيد تصريح الناطق العسكري
بذلك فيما يؤكد نائب وزير خارجيه الحوثيين
بان ما تعرض له اليمن
يعد يعد ايضا انتهاكا لسيادته وايضا ما ما
ما قامت به امريكا وبريطانيا امر او فعل س
سيدفع سيدفع ثمنهما ثمنه وهو ما اكده ايضا
محمد عبد السلام في ما نشره على موقع اكس
وهو ما اكد بانه عدوان سافر تعرضت له
اليمن و وذلك قامت به لحمايه اسرائيل
متهما اياهما بان ما قاما به هو لحمايه
اسرائيل ويعد ووصف ذلك بانه حماقه و
وعدوان غادر و
وهنا يؤكد ايضا ان اليمن سيستمر في موقفه
فهذا الهجمات التي قامت بها امريكا
وبريطانيا لن تثني اليمن عن استمرارها في
دعم ومسانده غزه حتى رفع الحصار وانهاء
العدوان عليها ويقول مراقبون ان الاستهداف
الذي شنه انصار الله في التاسع من يناير
والذي اكدوا انه تسبب في دمار او ضرر في
السفينه الحربيه الامريكيه حسب الناطق
العسكري باسم جماعه انصار الله هو الامر
الذي دفع امريكا وواشنطن لندن وواشنطن على
القيام بالهجوم ليله البارحه بعد ما يقارب
يومين من استهداف تلك
السفينه وكان الحوثيون قاموا
ب الهجوم على هذه السفينه بعد ايضا
انتقاما لمقتل عشره افراد من البحريه فهنا
نلاحظ
استمرار الفعل ورد الفعل من قبل الجانبين
الى اين ستصل هذه الدائره لا نعرف الى
ربما سيتوسع نطاق هذا الصراع